what's happening there reject nation
greg and john here today
we put out on the community post should
we watch zack snyder's zombie league and
you guys voted yes
it's gonna be reaction highlights can't
show the whole movie you know we love
that zack snyder loves his music but we
also have to make sure we're avoiding
like
claims and blocks mainly so that way
this can be visible for
everyone on all devices and around the
world that being said full length watch
along as we sync with the timecode will
be over at our patreon page but before
we
swing into any of this gotta thank
today's
video sponsor and that is gala games why
do you gotta hop in with me and why
can't i just say
i wanted to join him it's fine talk
about it what is it oh jewel gala games
is a fascinating new video game
development and publishing company whose
drive is creating excellent games and
putting the control and ownership
back in the hands of the players greg
just like the classic nintendo cards and
playstation discs of old my friend you
really wanted to say that huh absolutely
you know what i want to say zack snyder
would love this
because he obviously loves control
and they're doing this by taking
blockchain and nft based gaming
to the next level crypto words kryptoer
elon musk no i'm not gonna confuse you
all and myself
trying to explain blockchain's
non-fungible tokens i i understand it
really well but john watch try
explaining it for everyone else
you know what in the gala games
ecosystem once you're set up with a
gallon node
all of your in-game possessions they're
yours your skins any items you might
amass
they're all unique to you to do with as
you please
i understand this so what i think you're
saying is you could buy sell
trade or share like hoard them all for
yourself yeah
anything you want so the choice is truly
yours like zack snyder's control over
this movie gala's ultimate goal much
like exactly let's ask you what the goal
was
much like zach snyder's goal actually is
to create a supportive and eco-friendly
platform
shaped by its players that can foster
real social good
while also just providing an excellent
gaming experience and all that starts
with a gala node it's essentially your
hub for all things gala
owned by you oh cool ownership like zack
snyder
he loves owning things and having the
final say over them
and you can learn all about purchasing a
gallon node the games they have to offer
gala's referral program and everything
else they have to offer by hitting up
that link in the description box there's
also a link to their discord if you just
want to get your feet wet head over
there
send them some love use the links that's
cool
but what's today's video sponsor why do
we got to share this bedroom but what's
the sponsor it's gala games
oh they're the sponsor oh they're the i
thought we were just sharing something
we love
it's just what i love this is
oh yeah thinking about thompson for any
of these highlights 2 hours 20 minutes
sitting here
hey we did it for snyderco we can we
could do it for netflix
the payload
[Music]
why we need all this firepower to
protect it could be anything from a
briefcase nuke
to the original copy of the constitution
i got your little cousin
i feel like a comic book what are you
gonna do you
crazy crazy girl yeah yeah
okay oh is going to go according to plan
oh yeah dude this is going to go
so well and they're not going to cross
paths with those military guys at all
like
that's a good wedding day all right i
got one
things we shouldn't be home you're gonna
just make me say it out loud i honestly
don't
yeah it's called expositional dialogue
spit it out we need the theme man area
51
secret hanger autopsy
oh no come on
guys guys
[Music]
oh how hilarious
come on guys hustle up let's get this
thing out looks like she gave him some
road
dead
i guess they both met their climax
we've been in a serious accident
mothership we got numerous fatalities
for sure
get your men out of their horsemen if
they can't move
yeah yeah i copy
the laptop containing the original zac
it's the green lantern footage
stay away from it what
they said stay oh
whoa whoa
wait no no no no no we can't stop we got
to keep moving we're far enough away now
it's okay it is so not okay
all right all right all right
what was that bit bad news
hunting
holy [ __ ] are you kidding me that really
scared me
[Music]
that would be a good time to shoot it
[Music]
oh
cool
wow that's a fast turn
so it all started this one night with
this one
subject
gross i love it
i love it
she's killed like three random dudes
yeah
i love how spread out the words are on
the
yeah it's like a quirky comedy
so zack snyder's like mastered opening
montages huh yep
that's like his greatest skill
love that look oh man i gotta kill you
master's degree in philosophy
oh no oh
bad times ugh
oh wow how cool oh that is awesome
that is that is like a comic uh
that's how i think of dave bautista damn
he's like the jaw wick of this
the gun looks so tiny and damn like a
toy
[Applause]
that's that's zombie kill of the week
right there
that's right
[Music]
what a great opening montage yeah
look at this downfall in the chorus
eating of
contain it it's a good ball visual
prologue
yeah that's great
no what i thought she was going to be
like the main character she was going to
be
one of the best asses
no oh wow
wow wow
all that work
[Music]
that character's name is kate
[Laughter]
let the kids finish backing go on come
on
somebody says it a third time it's for
real
in case anything happens to me in the
next few days just make sure the kids
make it out to burst okay
these guards they don't give a [ __ ]
i can find my way out me and my kids
people that go in there they don't
always come back
just get it hey wait wait wait gita come
on
hey is everything okay here ladies
no way he's in this movie aids
volunteers nothing she didn't say
anything is that right volunteer kate
kate shut the [ __ ] up shut
the [ __ ] up okay what well
you're both within the margin of error
you better be on that bus volunteer
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
um
[ __ ] that's how cool guys cry
mr tanaka i'm in a tough spot called
impossible
i don't like you very much
so i hate giving you the satisfaction of
taking the job but
you're the best to gather your team
you'll need a helicopter pilot
and a safe cracker i'm gonna text you on
a dress
be there at 4pm tomorrow
you're freaking scorpion man you can do
it yourself get over here
at 4pm tomorrow
[Music]
yeah you mean vander i'll take 15
million each
assuming he'll do it
everybody else who isn't family nobody
needs to know our cut
no you're getting it what are you guys
doing here
we are putting together a crew for a job
yeah what does it pay
we make two million dollars for one
day's work two million dollars
i hate my life so deeply
[Laughter]
i meant thanks bud i'll see you bud
some chances told me you needed a safe
cracker
might be your amazing piece how would
you like to make 250 grand
for one day's work
do i represent your greatest chance of
opening it
i can with humility say yes
mr tanaka team's all here lovely to have
you
all gathered here today meet your target
the vegas bligh you can't fly into vegas
built the whole model and it's just made
for this plan alone
there is an abandoned rescue helicopter
on top of the north tower
sodom this should be a simple in and out
as they all always are ways such as
yourselves
ombre tough ombre
just land there stand in a circle shoot
make sure it looks really cool
you'll reach the casino in less than two
hours
there you'll find several non-lethal
deterrents you'll have to find a way to
trigger them
back at the main door our safe cracker
gets to work
she succumbs to the sheer dominance of
his gentle
wow he's really poetic about this heist
yeah yeah
all you have to do is load the money on
the helicopter
fly out into the sunset
like a resident evil movie or a game
[Music]
oh he's trying to get to kate obviously
seems like a goal of his
should not put that together and puts
him right in her pathway
what are you doing here i need to talk
to you no
no oh no kate's here i'm so confused on
where everything's set up
yeah she's she's right outside of vegas
do this one thing
and i can give you 15 million
million if you do dollars one thing for
me i will
damn you give all of it to her i guess
so
my man's got a death wish just keep like
a hundred dollars
fourteenth million nine hundred and
ninety nine
two you gotta like five billion dollars
that's a lot of money man
a million dollars i keep like some of it
yeah dave bautista is definitely gonna
die in this movie
and that's sad to know because he's
awesome in this film yeah
[Music]
you're all getting a head shot in two
seconds
hey hey you're the coyote right
take us in
you're kidding what is this she's just
giving us right at the quantum zone
really think i'd take her inside the
city
you really think i intend to take her
inside the city
i got some of the songs of the original
and some of them are covered some of
them yeah
which what's the key zack snyder which
which one gets the original one which
if this moment makes in the youtube cut
none of them none of the songs
no you won't know what song
damn middle fingers will work art look
at that thing yeah man
is probably an instagram handle bodies
on the wires
cool i mean the effects are phenomenal
yeah hey hey hey hey hey hey
what's wrong mom's gone [ __ ] break
really peter
try not to piss that off
he's awesome some of this cast is so
damn good
oh yeah what do you mean oh
the hell is going on what the hell are
you doing wow she is really bleeding
you took ankita i'm sorry
i waited kate as long as i could but at
the end of the day i'm coming with you
i'm telling you what's going to happen
claire
look i want to bond with you but not
like this
not what i intended when we reunited
if we see your friend great but you are
not to run off looking for her
this is life and death we need another
person
what the hell's going on here
yeah i'll make 20 [ __ ] grain
put your gun up idiot
okay it's not too late take natara
really looked like she was there yeah
i almost wasn't aware she wasn't
actually there
i know right
they're shamblers what's left of them
wow you should see what happens when it
rains
for a few hours they'll come back to
life
oh what please let it rain oh damn
that's
crazy gotta get some rain before the
movie is over how much rain
i think this moves pretty freaking cool
yeah helen's back get behind the car
go behind the car
what is this valentine
hey cummings let me see your gun for a
second what no no
i don't i don't know
she's gonna kill him
hey they won't care so long as we play
by their rules
she's sacrificing him it seems as though
what are you talking about they don't
think
if they come we kill them but we're
talking about the other ones
the alphas yes they're smarter they're
faster
they're [ __ ] no organized
she's coming who's coming what's coming
she was she no
please let me bond it please you know
a heads up about the world before going
in there would probably help them out a
little bit a little bit
yeah you'd go a long way that's a big
big old caveat
a big old piece of information you're
awesome and the scene's cool
however however yeah construction little
heads up before
it would have helped
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
just do it
did they come back yep the shamblers
if we want to go further we go indoors
ali let's go
[Music]
yeah this is so awesome
[Laughter]
it's like a living comic book it's so
cool
[Applause]
oh you might be alphas but there's one
alpha real alpha super alpha
magel megal alpha megalodon mega alpha
ultra mega one true alpha
alpha prime
does she have a baby in her zom baby
[Music]
he's bringing it back
pregnant we it's gonna be a boy
you're gonna deliver this baby
[Laughter]
what is the ritual cool
this is an elvis
new zombie rules
it's like that silent hill scene yeah
with the nurses
you know mostly seem pretty cool about
walking through this
gotcha [ __ ]
wow maybe she shouldn't have threatened
him beforehand or
[Music]
oh my god
put it together oh that is actually
really scary yeah god damn it put it
together
hey you killed the zombie damn nice
damn
[Applause]
whoa you got a dog
cool no oh
no come on it's like the lady in aliens
yeah oh [ __ ] what's her name
jeannette cool dude did they fight that
[ __ ]
oh
oh dude she is awesome yeah
she she better make it through god man
who is she
she had better make it through this yes
yes kill
murder
god
no double headshot
oh yo what a g
[Laughter]
you mother effort you dick
you oh that is so messed up what a dick
i thought she was right behind me what
happened what did you do
i didn't do anything she just started
shooting i wasn't even close to her oh
since he was back there with
go to
what do you mean she's done she's she's
not she no
now she's done come on
shoot my gas can
[Music]
dude this uh that was a great sequence
yeah that was a fantastic sequence yeah
i really ring the tension out of that
subversion it really had me going
look she might live with it yeah i know
oh crap the action on her
choreography too but yeah using them as
shields yeah strategically
really badass claustrophobia
situation damn it damn that one guy
it's not the fact that
you killed my mother it's that you never
showed up
after okay you
you weren't there i'm sorry that kate
that came out meaner than i meant it
no i understand oh
man let's just get this done
batista's so good i know
and they said his acting career wouldn't
go anywhere
i see why man i see why he
wants to do more substantial
[Laughter]
let me off the leash guys
[Music]
that's where the first pressure triggers
it's some kind of a booby trap
trust me if we could find something to
trigger it
man what the plan
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Applause]
uh
forget blood you know how much the whole
head of one of these things is worth
to my boss
[Music]
watch this ghouls now
wow
[Music]
good luck with that
as it was inevitable to everyone
what are you planning
dude i love their friendship so much
over this movie
[Music]
it's like the national anthem is playing
it's performing a z-section
whoa my goodness
whoa
oh they go to raise hell
[Music]
there's no more room in hell the dead
will walk the earth
zom baby
okay
i think it's so poetic that the zombies
camped out at the olympus
yeah i know where she went she's my
daughter
my brother i'm gonna get her back all
right i'm coming with you no you're not
i'm not gonna let you go out there alone
oh no
[Music]
wow holy [ __ ]
oh my god oh
damn oh that was
something hoo-hoo
freaking martial arts zombies
oh wow
oh come on man no you're like my
favorite
oh god damn it
no
they just became friends i know
they're the most endearing arc in the
whole movie
come on dieter save the day somehow no
i don't want to watch i don't want to
watch
oh
how did you get out of there
what
oh no
directed by zach smith all right
and uh catch up with the netflix show
coming soon
smart
i should remember that bag and yeah i
knew this was going
knew this was coming pete bite his head
off
bite his head off one clean bite
wow wow oh this is better toy with your
food
i like this yeah much better much better
wow
much better oh yeah oh yeah take that
take that
tiger
white tiger white zombie tiger
wait it's super the freud stephen fry
yeah
my favorite thing my favorite vegas
sigmund freud yeah i got that right
what you telling him yeah what are they
what are they communicating
wow damn it no i really liked her i did
too
oh crap oh she's still got the head
yeah drop it off the edge
you better find her man
and then you gotta give me whatever
money you do yeah just do your
in there man where you got your bank
account at home
we're just in the register at the diner
you cook at
keep your tips
oh but they can get their revenge
against d-bag guys yeah
all three of them together yeah they can
do it like that
[Laughter]
one last bite
[Applause]
[Music]
nice
that's one of zack snyder's inspirations
for this movie is back to the future
absolutely
the whole time just back to the future
three it's like aliens and george romero
and back to the future too
somewhere
[Music]
it's exhausting nice get in yeah
faster faster before zom daddy shows up
and go faster oh i am looking behind
my dude i see him in the background
jesus christ
right there just get in
okay
oh my goodness gracious
wait a
what did she minute clipped to the
shoulder or something
[Music]
oh god just doesn't stop
ah you knew it damn it
[Applause]
[Music]
wow what is that blue effect
oh it's like actual blood like what
blood looks like
underneath like without the whole movie
don't understand
i guess yeah isn't blood actually blue
until it's exposed to air yeah
yeah okay what is being exposed there i
don't know
damn it really felt like
oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah bad bad yeah
sick didn't make it that
took some of the kids a lot of hundos no
it's not millions
but i should get get his kids out of the
camp for good
[Music]
she's just been chilling in the red shot
yeah
that helicopter is full of the antidote
[Laughter]
i would be upset
you had an antidote all the time you're
gonna load us up with god i found you
i have a serum
what about the dude in the vault she's
just dead
i think he survived i think he's alive
right you gotta be alive here he comes
you might show us him he won't be
radiated
get some money
hey they do this obviously
i would love to for you guys to be able
to hear it yeah
that should be unlocked and that's it
locked in there is the best
that's thing all classmates survive
protect they got they all could have
done that
yeah man they all could have just hit it
the same hate in the save
and waited out for it was waiting for
the nuclear bomb
to the ironic twist of the unknown
bottoms up
cheers cheers
all right all right let's sit back down
there there we go
okay that's it
are you sure you're okay
it's either a ruse or there's something
in the champagne yeah the virus
airborne but it can't be in the
champagne they'd feel it
ugh
damn it no
good evening this year captain speaking
we will be beginning our final descent
into mexico city i'd like to ask you
please return your seat and fasten your
safety belt
[ __ ]
well kate got out of there alive yeah
kate made it
[Laughter]
okay made it gida died off screen
damn it oh
boy hey that stung at the end there yeah
like damn it it's weird how they have
this like little bit of a recurring
theme of how the decisions made in time
can be so costly starts off with just a
simple thing of i wasn't looking at the
road
this guy was getting roadhead bam zombie
outbreak
yeah kate decided to go off on her own
you know it's like you think about
they all could have survived in that
helicopter and got in a way
if tignataro had not vanished for a
minute
he just waited yeah or if they had just
gotten in there right away and took off
immediately yeah or if they had
stayed the same they might be fun yeah
and like a lot of dave bautista's
character deals so much with decisions
he made and suffering the consequences
for them
these little split decisions in time
make the big world of difference
guy beheading the queen not putting much
thought into that
yeah it's crazy a lot of uh a lot of
suffrage from decision making
seems like an awful lot of work to get
some blood of a
alpha bureau yeah
i don't know i like especially if the
alphas greet you with the outer
perimeter
it seems like you would just go in trap
one
there do all your why not just be honest
if that's all they need
yeah i guess i don't know i mean i guess
maybe he's not aware like
rituals don't like the ritual exists
yeah i mean
they obviously weren't aware of all this
but it's like we just needed one that
could have been the mission capture a
white walker
yeah bring it back
that's all they had to say no you would
i don't know you would get a
worse group of experts to agree to that
trip
i'll agree to pay them that much yeah if
you could afford to be like
screw 200 million you can't you probably
have 50 million dollars
[Laughter]
yeah can't afford it if it's already
been insured and all that
junk plus whatever extra fortune you
have
yeah that's frustrating i thought that
was a really cool movie yeah i thought
it was really cool
yeah i thought dave bautista was great
we stayed for credits that's what we do
here
i thought dave bautista was great i mean
most
mostly yeah my majority of them are
really good
really good i wish i uh committed to
memory any of their names other than
kate
all right the german guy the black guy
yeah great
take notary
the woman who seems plucked straight out
of aliens
oh yeah yeah yeah who's uh who was a
little earlier
oh oh i thought she was cooler than
the influencer guy yeah who i didn't
think it mounted a bunch in this movie
no i thought like she had way more of a
shining moment than
it seems like she had his plotline yeah
cause like he just was kind of there
holding it down like i i got a kick out
of that because i feel like most of the
time these days when influencers show up
it's to be a punchline and so it was
almost funny how just like
he's just here and he's solid and that's
his character
and uh i really thought the woman who is
not mackenzie davis was awesome
oh yeah you know what i'm talking about
when i say that right yeah yeah
like french coyote yeah yeah she's
terrific yeah yeah the world was
just so cool like the world was
really rich and zack snyder has really
mastered
his master opening montage oh dude like
damn
just like wow there's a whole it's a
whole story right here in this montage
that's why zack snyder needs to develop
a tv show because think how crazy the
opening credit scene would be
well you never want to skip it well yeah
i mean right
uh right right at the beginning like you
get it you get all the themes in there
and the plot and the prologue just the
loss
and yeah those split second revolutions
you only get one crack at
what this team being reassembled had to
go through
yeah get all that there yeah absolutely
strong stuff man
the painting can be with losing someone
you love right there at the beginning
getting you invested in this character
who doesn't have any dialogue
i know and i was like that was powerful
i care
like the movie's not perfect there are
some things that i think are a little
uh funky yeah i just thought the world
was so cool like i love
the it's like this apocalyptic landscape
all
in las vegas yeah yeah yeah and better
than resident evil extinction and i love
how it just started with
zombie and it just took over well that's
that's always the fun part is it's
always
isolating that that patient zero it
always starts in one point and then
becomes a catastrophe yeah let's talk
about it some more but we'll
throw some fancy mics in here just to
make it more interesting all right we
just drag these mics over here
because it's just the talking portion
yeah of the video
you want to be kind to your ears um but
yeah you know as we talked about during
the credits
uh i thought it was really enjoyable you
know honestly whenever you commit to
sitting down for
two and a half hours i'm like is this
going to be a slog
yes i'm going to be focused on back pain
but it's really
the halfway point there wasn't much
slow-mo
not really no i feel like the the
majority of the speed ramping happened
in the opening sequence yeah when you
were having you know little bits of like
speed up so it was more speeding up and
then you know slowing back down to
normal pace
majority during the day yeah absolutely
bright lush slo-mo
zack snyder movie yeah yeah
just the way people talked about it they
were like yeah it's a zack snyder movie
but i'm like this doesn't feel like a ah
to to the credit of it you know like
even whether this
it's not i'm not even really talking
about whether this is a
like a a an opinion about the movie
being like a good thing or a bad thing
it didn't feel like i was watching any
of the most like
previous zack snyder movies in the live
yeah you know what i mean like yeah it
didn't feel like that to me i felt like
this was
very different in so many ways are there
things
about it yes um but overall
no it just dawned on me huh donna
dawned on me while talking about this
that
yeah it wasn't much slow-mo it was all
during the day
yeah it's it's it has a lot of zack
snyder in it but it's not meme-ishly
zack snyder style
yeah you know yeah and i like i like the
meme-ish
zack snyder you know i do too champion
of the slow mo
zack snyder i think a lot of what he
does look like the music video the zack
snyder music video people clown on it
usually works on me as an aesthetic
piece even if i can see how it doesn't
fully complement the piece as a whole or
whatever
but well while the this this movie i
thought had a really interesting tone
because the the tone of it um
it's a it it leans toward the
more serious side on the tone yet it
managed to still be
overall have like this fun undertone to
it all
yeah i mean because it comes to the
characters and it comes through the fact
of like
this this crazy world and adventure you
know yeah yeah and it's funny to see you
know more of the zack snyder
humor coming out in recent times you
know because so much of this
does kind of rest on you know the
ensembles dynamics and there is a lot of
like
fun to be had in that as much as it also
takes its time for at least certain
characters to have their
serious backstory stuff well dude dave
bautista was
excellent he was committed yeah he was
he's terrific yeah he's the lead
and he's he's what you want in an action
star it really hit me in this moment
like i've i've always not always but
ever since that scene in blade runner
2049
um wherever for a lot of us said that
like
you really act my dude's an actor yeah
that's big and cool and fun and he's
yeah i actually got some chops but i
haven't really had that itch to
see dave bautista lead a movie still
even after that i haven't had that after
this
and and then after watching this movie
i'm like whoa
yeah i every time he was on screen he
was
great and he's got like a couple he's
got like
several monologues in this movie or not
if not monologues he's got
scenes where he is carrying majority of
the dialogue
and he's wonderful so natural like
nothing feels forced at all
his intimate moments especially yeah we
just were actually breathing
scenes that touched me in various ways
you know yeah
yeah you perv and also you said touched
me so you know you gotta make the
comment
and even in some of the fighting moments
i thought were so
good like he understands the emotional
weight of some of the
like the most obvious primal example is
when the woman
gets her head snapped um and then the
bone
for tubes yeah
but um with with that scene like even
when he was doing that
like that was the there's such a cool
fighting moment for dave bautista to be
taking all those zombies yeah while the
rest of the crew
just hung around in the back he's
fighting all of them but he's like
on the verge of tears the entire time
he's fighting them because of the
the the loss of the woman who just five
minutes ago was like you know you still
got a shot with me i
love you money i just buddy
to ride you on the way out of here and
then
oh cool i got a second shot oh wait yeah
yeah yeah absolutely
i mean part partial criticism for me
is this and this is one of the partial
crew like there's someone i'm like man
whatever
and then they're ones that i'm like i
gotta got a big criticism about it but
to me i didn't really pick up on any
romantic chemistry between them so when
it came out i was like
oh you know what i didn't i i i thought
you might have just been friends i was
more caught up on the fact that he had a
dead wife
you know yeah i didn't really think of
them as romantic or sexual chemistry
even
i didn't really either and i mean
thinking back to the way early scene
when they're on the hood of his car and
he's recruiting her like
parts of me are like i guess i can kind
of see their like comfortable
familiarity but yeah as a plot point it
is sort of like an out of nowhere thing
that then with her death being so close
behind it feels like a
a way to sort of ramp up the stakes in a
way that wasn't super
natural it didn't feel altogether
natural perhaps
yeah yeah for sure um and yeah the rest
of the cast was great theo rossi that's
his [ __ ] name
yeah anarchy shades in uh
luke cage world of the forgotten marvel
cinematic universe
that's the official uh universe name
yeah and then
this guy he's the famous german dude
yeah matthias schweighofer
he was great yeah he i i loved
his and omari hardwick's relationship
the most throughout this movie
that was one of the most natural arcs
that like i
i caught me part way through i was like
damn they made an ark out of this
this is so nice you know right and it's
it solidified
with the uh the fist bump yeah because
you wouldn't do it earlier
yeah that was really great yeah their
chemistry together was awesome and
omari was a character who i i didn't
really care like as the
he was that there's some of these
characters like when they show up you're
like
yes i love him i love that character
yeah take notaro
yeah oh yeah for the second she showed
up right away like oh you're great
uh dave bautista um matthias theater
this is character's name i'm gonna go by
character those characters
right away you have that initial
connection with them of
i love them and amari harwick uh
then we have the imdb in front of us van
van der rohe
van der rohe i didn't feel that way with
him but as the film progressed
i be i was like oh i love this guy yeah
it [ __ ] broke my heart at the end i'm
like damn it manny yeah
i was like please get your revenge man
go visit hiroyuki sonata
and give him what far ah no this is just
the setup to the
to the rest of the outbreak isn't it i
thought the actress who played
kate did a serviceable did a good job
she's good
weirdly i it's one of those like weird
opinions
of no she did good she was good yeah but
for some reason i feel like
she should have been like this grand
performance for summer was like great
performance but i thought she did a good
job
it's a bit of a thankless role i think
because they let them really
express the emotion of their history but
their history is pretty familiar history
and so i
i thought her performance was it's at
its best at the very end like when she's
mourning
after the loss of of dave bautista like
that's when i bought her the most well i
mean yeah i mean
she had her great scenes were all with
david
yeah those were all like she's great in
all those scenes and that history felt
very palpable
um as we're watching it yeah when it
came time for the real heavy [ __ ] she
fully delivered yeah but the rest of the
time i mean she's sort of a device
to help develop or put obstacles in the
way of dave bautista's
character and nora r nazita lily the
coyote
uh oh man she was she's incredibly bad
also was a
show stealer for sure any time she was
talking i was just so into i'm like
you know i will listen i've i've totally
forgotten that you have like the most
expositional dialogue
like she delivers it so well with such
intensity and so on the edge is this one
character who's like
no i actually understand them as a
people not just a zombie thing you gotta
shoot
yeah you know and all that level of like
like uh all you could feel all the
trauma
and the of everything she's had to
witness all the death she's had to
witness
and yet with this complex understanding
of
that these are just a new kind of
living breed of thoughts and emotions on
display they're not just zombies they
have an
order and they have some kind of agenda
and they seem to want to perpetuate
their existence
and the zombies i don't even want to
call them zombies but you know the movie
calls them zombies i don't even want to
call them zombies
uh it worked really well i think
it's it's kind i think it can be a
little tricky when you give this
much emotion and personality to your
zombies
um you can kind of go a little too
far with it but here i thought
it i loved how there were all these
different stages on display i
wish we got the one they set up at the
beginning when they walked
walk into vegas passes uh past the
crates and
into the actual zone of vegas and they
talk about the rain and how that would
activate
that would have been i it doesn't look
like it's gonna rain today
but damn that would have been cool yeah
that was one of those things where i i
was almost certain like no yeah that's
gonna be like towards the end it's gonna
be one of the
ways in which they are screwed when
trying to get out of the city but but
nah it's just something that i'm sure
they'll pay off when uh the
anime series hits netflix well there's a
really neat visual language
really on display in the first like 20
minutes of this movie especially
in the in the prologue um like the
prologue encompasses
like the first zombie and then all the
vegas with the credits
because when that guy breaks out um
head zombie man when he breaks up
alpha zombie man um everyone turns and
they and they're just like
regular zombies but they all line up
behind him showing
there's a hierarchy and they're not just
regular zombies but when they do their
montage
they're just like regular zombies you
know like when they're watching the
infestation and it's spread and all of
vegas collapsing it's just
they're just all regular zombies so you
so it thrusts you into the world of
other just regular zombies
so it's effective when they go into the
zone
and then suddenly you got like these
like mad max looking apocalyptic
like what the hell like you're with the
characters there
and i forgot about the trailer and to be
like
oh yeah there's something it's it you do
feel that
that scary effect of oh [ __ ] these guys
like think and feel they're like
tribal yeah yeah they have their own way
of getting
through all the way yeah that they just
communicate through these vile screeches
and stuff like that and i loved
the performers they got to play those
roles especially like the princess one
because like it just seems like they got
to go
full creature with those performances
and whatnot and in a zombie movie
from a physical perspective that was a
cool thing because you know like the
walking dead has
has made famous like zombie school
there's like a legitimate way to
approach it and so those were kind of a
way of spicing things up in a very
gripping kind of comic book style way
but there is i have a couple of
questions
like uh how are how do they live if
they're not
feeding uh that's it yeah that didn't
make any sense
like is that what the hibernation thing
is for or do enough people just keep
breaking in here that i guess
you have enough food you can't feed all
those i was gonna say yeah
like it seems like there's tons and tons
and tons of they're all just chilling in
olympus
yeah yeah absolutely i don't know that's
a good question and then they
and then they finally get a guy like
turn him yeah
i'm like you guys could all just be
snacking on them
i guess they don't need to feed maybe
not
a lot or something well they don't seem
like they feed
for hunger yeah it seems like they they
just
like bite you up to incapacitate you
although i mean like the one guy at the
end who you know
sacrificed himself it looked like they
were all swarming to eat
i don't know that is a little bit of a
muddy thing about this movie because
it mostly prioritizes the bite the bite
is what you got to avoid
do they want to eat i don't know yeah
see they're like
they need to eat that's the question
there are layers there where i was a
little confused
and there are other layers where i like
how they don't fully lay everything out
like
they they really establish they're very
uh they're ritualistic
that's very that's made super clear in
fact
i think it's what they said they're
ritualistic
and i like how you don't really
like when the when uh theo rossi is
being dragged around there
they don't lay out what's exactly
they're doing and what the ritual is and
and i like that a lot but there are like
some of the rules
some of the rules of them are a tad
confusing
but then there's other parts that i
think to the new
rules that are awesome of like when
they're hibernating
that's a cool idea i love that they have
that included in here
and it makes for a great scary asset
piece
because they all decided to hibernate we
need the lights off you know and they
need to
vibe out pick your favorite pose to
sleep in
because that's how you're going to wake
up yeah and then having that that woman
sneak around was um
cause there's not a whole lot of action
in here like spread out right
there's a lot of tense scenes there's a
lot of cool visuals there's not like
necessarily
action scenes throughout constant action
yeah you get in the beginning you get it
when they're
uh that the the sneaking around which i
which weirdly to me is my favorite
sequence and it's not like all of them
are really
heavily involved but that i think that
was the one that you're expecting it to
go a certain way and it just kept
surprising me yeah absolutely and i
think that's why
that's my favorite one i expected that
scene to end like this like if she
realizes yeah then it's like oh here
comes a zombie she's done
and then yeah like they they that was
some of the best stuff throughout the
movie is those moments where they either
throw you into a character's perspective
with no information
lost with them into that tension like
with theorazi or yeah
that sequence was was such a highlight
because
it's also just like so well
choreographed and so tense and fried
yeah
yeah it was the most like john wiki the
most you could call it
like just like the cool like stab
moments shotgun and just like watching
her break out and the way they
toy with your heartstrings because you
know she's getting [ __ ] over by this
[ __ ]
yeah yeah which was a character that i
do want to get into that
i don't know i don't really like the way
he was written there's parts of this
script that i just
don't really care for yeah it's i think
i think that's the thing with zack
snyder is like you need to
match him with like a great writer i
heard somebody
express amusing of of what this might be
if
james gunn had written it again like he
did with dawn of the dead
and i could see you know a want for that
because too there are times where like
the dialogue is cool
and it certainly has flavor but in
certain characters delivery
it does start to feel like dialogue um
so sometimes it can kind of step on its
own feet that way too i feel like
yeah well there's there's like plotting
like some of the dialogue absolutely
yeah it's like super stylized to the
point where it's distracting
and uh the way some of the charac even
theo like theo rossi
i like him because he's theo rossi yeah
but the way his character was done he's
such an evil guy who loves to be evil
he it was such like a like of course
this guy works
a guy like that would likely exist in
this world
yeah and then there were some things
where
i thought the payoff for bringing him
was good yes ah
what do you mean oh you mean you need to
sacrifice him yeah yeah i don't really
care if i'm turning
yeah yeah yeah but like because i was
there to surf for like they can finally
kill him you know get that cathartic
feeling and yeah sometimes it was just
so on the nose with their dialogue but
even then i don't really kind of give a
[ __ ] it's more of like actually plot
[ __ ] that i i didn't care for
like i don't the whole thing with the
with the woman
going in and with the the mother
uh i actually think that could have
completely been
eliminated from here it does like it it
seems like it all
is just a complicated sidebar because
the thing about zack snyder is i feel
like he gets he's in the lucky position
where he gets to make
the version of the script before the
hollywood exec comes in and is like okay
all these character bits we got to pair
this down in 90 minutes
so it's like everything gets expanded
upon and everything gets character and
that plotline never transcended feeling
like it's
just an attachment to dave bautista's
character and it's
all kind of serving that well it's just
a plot device to get kate in there with
them which i think
is fine initially i actually think
especially since they're killing off
everyone in the movie
yeah it might have been more effective
if they just find her dead or she is a
zombie like they fail
to go with i that is the only time i
found myself
kind of doing a little rewrite in my
head because i'm not that guy
generally to do that it'll only if it
like pops up in my head because
it wasn't that part of the finale when
kate went away and then they have to
look for her
where i was like okay this is starting
to feel a little over stuffed and then i
got
pretty annoyed with kate in that moment
because a nuclear bomb is coming
yeah you know they haven't spotted
curved you know what this is going to do
to your dad in this moment
and they find her and if kate didn't do
all that they might have gone to the
helicopter
oh no if kate didn't do any of that they
definitely you know they would have gone
and it would have been absolutely fine
so i was annoyed by that but i was like
all right you get the emotional death
scene and of dave bautista and all that
okay
all right fine but then when the
helicopter crashes
that doesn't even what happened to gita
nothing they don't acknowledge anything
and they don't seem to care nope and i
was like well all that [ __ ] that you
made us go through for you trying to get
her
uh i was like well it would have been
better if you just found her and she was
the dead or a zombie
yeah yeah or something like or if kate
had made some kind of sacrifice gita
gets saved and she doesn't make it out
or something and dave bautista
has to like weirdly live with that this
sort of thing like i'm gonna keep
keeping you safe on the way out of here
even though my daughter's gone now and
i'm all messed up from that like yeah
it felt like a large tact on
thing to create some tension the second
[ __ ] because it seemed like it was so
obvious day about like food said it's so
early on
like it was so obvious dave bautista was
gonna die
and to me i i don't mind like
getting such a strong inkling the
character will die
and then having an execution a good
execution but there were plot points
that that bothered me
um like everything with the helicopter
showing up like tigmatar didn't need to
disappear and then it just became
so obvious what was gonna happen next
like you guys are dragging out
this moment you're relishing too much in
it that guy's gonna show okay he's
okay now he's gonna talk behind him okay
it's all going by the numbers to get
dave bautista to die now
yeah um so it seemed like no he has to
die i'm like yeah okay i actually agree
i think dave bautista has to die i agree
with that
like yeah make him die but come on that
was a little too
generic while it's cool to watch like
the helicopter secret like that was all
really like
every visual moment was awesome
sometimes the focus thing was a little
distracting eve most of the time not
really i don't know how to describe it
you provide
oh he's got these super long lenses
where you can like really see the glass
all the time where it looks like
ghosting and yeah it looks like they're
outlined
like yeah characters like outlines yeah
he loves a certain kind of lensing
well that's this is the first movie to
use it yeah or at least to this degree
yeah
yeah because it was it was just the new
slime it was so excessive and there were
times where i wasn't exactly sure
what the purpose of filming it like that
was to make it easier to crop take
notaro into frames
did help actually yeah i mean because
you could just yeah i have a nice
blurred pattern to the film's credit you
know
if you if you weren't made aware of that
i don't think you would notice it i
don't think so and as people who were
very much made well aware of it it was
distracting at first so you start
noticing like you notice because you
don't notice
well i mean in the beginning shots
especially like when they're when
they're with
um hiroyuki sonata's character all them
and the way they like cut to the group
but then when they cut to her
it's only her yeah absolutely because i
clearly had to insert her right
um and that's when i would notice like
okay yeah she wasn't there she wasn't
there
and then when it looked like she was
there it'd be like oh cool
now i'm aware that it looks like she's
there when i know she's not there
but after a while i actually completely
forgot about that yeah there was a point
where i completely
in the finale completely forgot about
that i was so
into it that i had stopped remembering
the whole filmmaking thing
yeah yeah of what went wrong with
replacing and stuff well and it's weird
because watching the movie too it's like
i can't even imagine
him in this role like she is so natural
in it that it just seems like it was
always meant to be
yeah it didn't look like they tried
getting uh a christielia type
no no it seemed like they just went the
complete opposite way and they like kind
of let her improvise
yeah and from what i have seen she was
the only choice for them so like good
good
call then she was fantastic absolutely
definitely a scene stealing she
interacted and delivered her lines to
people as if she i don't know when she
was there when she was not
how much prep and how like did you watch
everyone's dailies first or what
yeah she was great yeah um yeah there
are some parts
too to the plotting that i i thought
were a little bit uh jumbled like it's
something that sometimes they wanted to
have like this political commentary that
they didn't
fully commit to or it's always
chattering on that on the fringes
yeah it's always like details to make
the world feel more lived in but it's
not
really what the movie's trying to get at
i feel like we'll see in like bvs
ultimate edition
that's a big thing they do is cut to the
media and how they're
interpreting this larger than life
situation and i think it's
used to wonderful effect that really
helps build the tension and
stakes whereas here uh at times i
thought they were and then other times
it was like oh they need the television
on to learn about the new coming
yeah i mean pretty much that's the one
main thing it does is it gives you a
reason to pay attention to the news
that yeah yeah extra plot beat but there
were like certain things where it
because sometimes the comedy seemed a
bit off to me so like sometimes it was
so
great like the performers were hilarious
at times
and then sometimes it was a little off
yeah like with some of the things they
were saying about like the
how the president's talking about [ __ ]
on the oh yeah
i mean she's holding the head and she
makes the joke
yeah there's a certain like action movie
or like
action satire again i almost thought of
like a verhoeven movie where it seems
like it wants to have like a politically
satirical angle of sorts and part of me
was like well maybe it's like a
like a half-hearted trump riff or
something because like you know clearly
they're
sending up a non-professional sounding
president
but it made me wonder throughout the
movie like when was this written and
conceived because some of it seems like
it's even more relevant than ever with
the way that they have like
their camp set up and it's like don't
even
demonstrate just argumentative qualities
because then they might you know like
mess with your temperature and throw you
into the quarantine and flex said that
this is
the snyder cut yeah i mean you know
it does i wonder yeah where the
political
inspirations came from what year
all those things were finalized but yeah
some of that humor does
feel like comic book humor thrown on top
whereas some stuff feels like it's very
naturally from the characters
like i'll be honest i i think that the
that there's
so like so much of this i i thought was
so
great majority of it i did i actually i
love the visual language to it as much
as it says that sometimes
it's a little distracting i actually
thought it was so cool
a lot of the time the way it looked you
know because it really
it's not based on anything but it felt
like i'm watching a graphic novel
absolutely like more than actually
watching bbsr or justice like
it just felt like more like a graphic
novel than any of those
which is strange to me yeah it really
did and i and i felt like they
brought that to life so well and i think
there is a really cool world to explore
here
and i did feel like a bit annoyed at the
end and and i was like really bummed
when
the when the dude uh marty hardwick's
character is
in fact a bit like that i i wanted one
win one of the dead zombies either
or at least if they had to keep that to
have him turn
right in front of of hiroyuki sonata's
character or something like i kept
thinking like he's going on his jet
right he's gotta go find him
yeah there's some weird ways hiraoki
sonata's character is also written
yeah i think his introduction scene was
jarringly edited
a bit it was like so fast i'm like well
let's
get to it but uh
but i think hiroki sonata is just one of
those actors that like even if there's
something off about the writing i'm like
he just
shows up she shows up and just makes it
better every time
yeah and i mean you know there's a lot
of great work across the board and
that's i guess the
the frustrating thing about the movie is
that when the dialogue falters
or the plot points start to feel wrote
it's like ah damn
there are examples in the same movie of
you making better choices
yeah and so that's what becomes
frustrating is that you know certain
things do keep it from feeling like this
could have been like even great like
this is really cool i think but it could
have been
freaking great that's i know i think
that there's a lot of
amazing things in this movie that when
something is off or not quite executed
well in our opinion obviously you know
some people might think it's perfect
uh but in our opinion it it
it which it shines such a light on when
it wasn't
clicking yeah yeah yeah it just makes
those scenes glare more
exactly because because so much of this
movie is great yeah that when
something's not great it's like oh
that's a little
i really noticed it yeah enough
prominent times of you going damn i i
didn't expect it to go down this way
yeah it's kind of a let down when you're
like oh i saw this coming from the very
especially the reveal of the actual
mission as we talked about in the
credits was like
come on you know yeah i mean that's so
it's so it's like it didn't need to be
nested i'm like i believe that he wants
to get his 200 million dollars
that's the thing is making more money in
there make it 500 million then you know
yeah yeah this is a personal gripe but
that whole thing of like you can make
your own
zombie army i'm like that's a dumb idea
science and military folks that's a bad
idea it's a terrible trope like i i
i'll even go with you to the point of
yeah bring some blood back bring a head
back to test whatever but the the idea
that you want to create your own zombie
army i think is very dumb
yeah is that being the point it's it's a
dumb idea and
sometimes in like these other bigger
franchise building things which i didn't
i never thought to myself oh you're
doing that to build a franchise like my
mind didn't ever
go there with anything but sometimes it
felt like
when i looking back now i feel like some
of those things were planted for that
purpose
yeah um does that make sense yeah yeah
yeah yeah
it's like because it's not necessarily
leading directly to a sequel
but we know it is leading to other media
in its world it's like omari hardwick
being bit he's not in the quarantine
zone he's not in vegas he's outside this
could lead to
the world now having yeah absolutely but
i love the see
i love the world of
everywhere is pretty much fine yes
but what happened yeah
i love that yeah like that is such a
cool world and i didn't quite
catch on to that in the trailers yeah
absolutely the trailers made i wasn't
entirely sure
if it was only vegas or if it was like
nah there's a thing happening but
there's a major problem in vegas
um but yeah when they make that clear in
here i'm like that's a
really neat idea yeah you know
escape from new york at it exactly
because there are these escape from new
york
aliens vi it's pretty it really feels
like those two
smashed into here but zack snyder
helming it and uh
yeah just with zack snyder's dawn of the
dead on top yeah
yeah yeah exactly um but overall
very i i i i'll say i was
i only got like a little bit antsy and
frustrated when kate was going to go
rescue person then it just started
becoming a bunch of
tropes and conventions and predictable
cliches
uh in the finale parts that's when i
started getting like a little
actual the first time i was actually
getting frustrated with those were the
first times
i was like god damn it but that's also
like two hours into this two hours yeah
oh man that's we lost me an hour in it
was like two it was way into it
yeah um when i started it was towards
the
the right film yeah so i i
i and so yeah that's like the biggest
reason why i can be like no i still
overall enjoyed it uh quite a bit and it
was
pretty easy to sit here yeah i mean have
fun with it yeah
you hear you know two and a half hour
zack snyder zombie movie there are a lot
of things i think at that prospect that
you could bulk or
clown at and you know what i mean i
think this is like above average
blockbuster movie like yeah it's got an
engrossing lore it's got some really
cool actions beautifully shot and it
again has that
this easily could have made you not care
about the people and i i cared about a
pretty good amount absolutely
like that's that's the most that's an
important quality i cared about
i care about at least half of them you
know yeah and that's the thing is i feel
like if it had been another filmmaker i
think a lot of that stuff would have
been forcibly trimmed but
zack snyder like for for worse sometimes
but also for better
can get those like cool pulpy characters
who are types
and then actually have a little bit of
time to develop them so that we do care
exactly yeah and this movie definitely
benefits from that
say right now off of a fresh experience
i would say like 7.5 out of 10.
yeah i think that's probably fair yeah
we can be in agreeance maybe like a 7.8
yeah yeah say that yeah seven point
eight yeah you doing because it's like i
wanna say eight but i don't quite want
there's
certain things that are clever enough or
that are surprising enough or that are
good enough where you're like oh yeah
hell yeah and then you look at the hole
and you're like
i gotta ding you for a couple things
that just i know you have
more inspiration than you know yeah but
but the thing is i never actually felt
like it came down to
and this isn't just being some zack
snyder's stan i don't
feel like it ultimately was the problem
with the direction
or maybe it is maybe it is zack snyder
from the direction of
working directing his writer or
directing or like you know
figuring out the flow of the script or
being like hey this is
not working um there's that or maybe he
didn't think it was all cool
yeah i think actually it's the kind of
guy i feel like no it's all cool
i'm inclined to believe that just
because at this point now and especially
with netflix i mean their bag even
before zack snyder was yeah we let
people have pretty good amount of
control
so i feel like he can be held
responsible for a lot of things
in in this movie for sure but the the
immediate issue
isn't the directing itself it it really
was the uh
writing yeah the script in some parts
but even to that degree i'm like
i still [ __ ] i i'd barely i would i
would be in and out of noticing when it
was better
yeah yeah better it's better than
average and he seems like he allows his
actors to really elevate the material
for sure yeah see he seems like he picks
people who he wants to take it and run
with it
all right guys what'd you think of army
of the dead leave your thoughts down
below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button
and hey last but not least
mikhail the safe cracker guy reminded me
of you
i know you're not from germany but i
thought i was like i know we're gonna
shout somebody out and i could see
mikhail with those specs
in this role and uh i don't know i just
wanted to shout you out every time i see
your profile pic on our patreon just
makes me smile i wish
i could hear your voice hear your accent
we could hang out sometime
have a drink lament the james bond is
just never
ever gonna come out but uh yeah man i
hope you're doing well
and uh i hope that you saw and enjoyed
this movie and took
notes because when i write my zombie
movie you're getting a role the guy
you're the guy thank you mikhail for
being you you're an amazing dude you're
sexy as hell
love you buddy